hello everyone and welcome back to some
60 frames-per-second action from round
six of the 2019 us championship its
former World Chess Championship
challenger Fabiano Caruana versus
jeffrey young we already seen one game
where Jeffrey defeated the last year's
champion similar Shanklin and we already
seen one game where Caruana
missed a win against Dominguez and this
is a really exciting game it does come
from a brilliant defense but you'll see
it's exciting nonetheless and I have
prepared the standings after round six
so you'll get to enjoy that as well but
only after we check out the game so
without further ado Caruana has the
white pieces and he opens with E for let
me just fix that we have E 5 by Xiang
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 Bishop b5 rule
opus is on the board and as we already
mentioned Knight to f6 we have the
Berlin defense with d3 the the most
popular line and nowadays Bishop to c5
and now Bishop captures D captures and
here we have castles by Caruana Queen to
e7 by Black Knight B to d2 and Bishop to
g4 this is all been played before so
this is I believe both of them are well
within their opening preparation Bishop
to h5 now comes a three black responds
with a five and Knight to c4 Knight to
d7 by black we have g4 by white pushing
the bishop further back Bishop to g6 and
now b4 and here we reach a position that
was already on the board in a game
between Vishwanathan Anand and Hikaru
Nakamura in the 2017 same fluid blitz
challenge that game ended in a draw but
it it went to pawn captures and then on
and when the Bishop to g5 wouldn't
attack on the Queen f6 and then a
capture Sun before it was a really
exciting game in the end it ended in a
draw but here it's actually Geoffrey who
deviates from from this well-known game
with Bishop to b6
so we we could say that it was he either
over the board spur of the moment that
he decided to do this or he was
well-prepared up until this point and
this is now a surprise for Fabiano and
and well either way we have a completely
new game now they are already from move
12 here karana goes B captures on a5
Bishop captures on 85 and now Bishop to
b2 with a triple attack against d5 pawn
and here f6
she um defends it and it's a well not
nothing out of the ordinary for black to
actually play f6 in any line of the
Berlin defense and here comes a move
that really surprises me here karana
played Knight captures on a five-night
to h4 followed by Knight to f5 seems to
be the way to go and it is what Caruana
decided for his plan after capturing in
the bishop I just don't see why you
would capture the bishop
you can always capture it there's no way
black can avoid you capturing it I mean
yeah there are no squares you can use
use for the bishop and whatever you do
wife can always capture it so I don't
see the point in capturing it
immediately but you know he he was the
world's championship Challenger so what
do I know but if any of you have an idea
of why would you actually capture the
bishop do sure I mean in the comments
Knight captures we rook captures on 85
and now comes Knight to h4 now going for
the f5 square it will be an excellent
outpost for White's night with castles
by Shion and not Knight to f5 attacking
the Queen and here you could capture it
I mean it is a monster night but then
black gets a semi-open G file for his
rookie can go King to h2 double rooks on
the G file and he will push for
advantage that way
she um decides to go Queen to e6 just
getting the Queen out of the way and now
King to h2 Khurana makes room on the G
file for his rooks we have a c5 black
has a CC pawn so of course he wants to
get rid of at least one of them and he
will do so by pushing c4 and attacking
Caruana center we have h4 carolina now
starts his march on the King side we
have c4 and h5 Bishop to f7 getting out
of the way and rook to g1 just nicely
positioning that rook on the G file C
capture son d 3c captures
look the b5 going after the bishop on b2
so this is why I said that it was really
weird for that night to capture the
bishop immediately you just you just
give black ideas but okay Bishop to c1
now this bishop will join the attack
using this diagonal we have a king to h8
by black perhaps preparing roof to g8
Bishop to e3 now improving the position
of the bishop and rook to b3 here blacks
blacks rook is nicely protected by both
the Queen and the bishop and the black
might use the idea of Queen to a6 the
pile up against the weak d3 poem karana
has we have looked to g3 after the
bishop moves the rook will also serve as
a defender of the d3 pawn but also once
the Queen moves you will be able to
double rooks on the G file here we have
c5 by black Queen to e2 making room for
the rook and here black has to make a
choice here black can go Queen to a6
going after the d3 pawn and here just
rook a to g1 and if you capture Queen
captures on d3 then white will trade
back Queen captures rook captures and
now Bishop to h6 this is the move
Caruana had in mind where you open up an
attack against the rook on d3 but also
pressure g7 so once black captures rook
captures you would get Bishop captures
with check King g8 rook captures on g3
now I have to move the rook rook the egg
and here we would get this position
where the material and the board is
equal
but it would be an opposite opposite
called bishop in him about Corwin as
position would be somewhat better due to
such nice activity of the pieces so
after Queen to d2 young does not opt for
this Queen to a6 idea but rather he
pushes jisuk g5 she would like to close
up the King side and if he if he was
able to do so then surely the attack
would stop but Kerwin is not interested
he plays H captures on g6 on pass on we
have Bishop captures and only now he
plays a for preparing to pull the pawn
but also not making it a target on a 3
and now Queen to a6 by Shion going after
the d3 pawn
so we have the dissimilar line Bishop h6
going after the rook look the g8 now
defending the g7 square of course and
rook a to g1 here
Khurana says ok I don't need my a for
pawn and it's well it's very interesting
if she can capture it and survive the
attack the best the best move for black
here is just Queen to e6 but you will
know that only after you see why she
only decided it was okay to capture the
pawn he played Queen captures on a4 and
now feel free to pause the video and try
to find Cara Juana's idea that he played
in this game I'll give you a couple of
seconds if you want to decide whether to
do it or not for those of you who were
able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
Punisher off of pong grabbers and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the idea is Knights the e7 not not
all that difficult to spot as it
challenges the rockin g8 you have to
move at the best regards g7 and f8 so
whatever you do for example if you move
it let's say rook e8 you attack the
knight then you get Knight captures on
g6 pawn captures and now g5 and the
white is breaking through f5 you can
capture and now finally you cannot
recapture but black will then have a
very impressive pawn and f6 if you
capture Queen h5 and the black is
getting checkmated very soon so here
after Knight to e7 zhong decided that it
was not possible to to save the rook he
played a queen to d4 just you know
improving the position of the pieces
preparing rook to be 2 with an attack on
the Queen but also with a double attack
against the f2 pawn as you see here and
now you can go back you to go back
Bishop to e3 just kicking the Queen away
from such a nasty square or you can go
with kuranes idea he played Queen to d1
now attacking the rook and also inviting
rook to be - so here c4 was played young
decided to protect the rook and also if
pawn captures then Queen will be able to
capture on d1 but now this is just too
slow karana just captures the rook on g8
with nice captures and g8 King captures
and now D captures in c4
Khurana now doesn't mind trading Queens
but first we have rope capture Sanji
three Queen captures and DeForest played
pawn captures on d4 and now King
captures on g3 and Bishop captures on e4
so if you count everything for the price
of the exchange Chun is up one pawn and
it's a it's actually a very nice point
it's it's a passed pawn already on d4 so
rook to d1 karana puts the rock in front
of the pawn we have d3 the bishop now
protects the pawn and every kicking the
bishop back with bishop the g6 and now
rook to a1 we have King to f7 you don't
want to allow any rook thx while the
bishop controls these squares we have
rook to a 7 and now comes Knight to c5
it's very useful that the Bishop covers
the D 2 square you can never put it upon
2 D 2 with Bishop to e3 now attacking
the knight and once you remove the
defender of the b7 pawn well Blackwell
just and white will just capture and you
know haste in his victory here Shion
played a very interesting move kinked ei
he offers an entire piece just just so
he he will be able to push his bone
forward and Carolina calculates
precisely karana plays Bishop captures
on c5 with d2 now how do you prevent the
queening of the pawn that's well that's
something you have to figure out karana
figured that out but you know you are
comfortable at your own home so once
again pause the video here and win this
position with the white pieces of what
do you play here I'll give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent winner of games that should be
worn and for those of you who just want
to enjoy it so if you found Luke to a 1
then you would not be winning this game
just Bishop to c2 and well the point is
getting promoted you will have to give
up your look and it will be it will be a
draw but if you found a different move
the move Caruana played which is not
rook to e1 but rather rook to e8 check
then you definitely deserve this win so
first you you give a check we have king
to d7 by black and now comes
to be six this is the move you had to
find now even if why even if black
brings a queen into the game let's say
you do this rook e8 check King moves you
just you just pick up the Queen and now
you enjoy this winning endgame
so after King 2b after Bishop to b6
final attempt by Shion was King to c6 at
least you know he will he will grab the
bishop but here Khurana just said no no
thank you sir he played the Queen to
Bishop to a5 and now the pawn from c4
create and the bishop create a wall
against the black King so you can no
longer harass the bishop and whatever
you do here we'll just we'll just well
and end in a win now if you promote to a
queen a queen now you don't have a check
to pick up the Queen but now you get
rook checks here and then when the King
moves whatever you do let's say well
here now you deliver check King moves
and now you pick up the Queen so it's
pretty much the same idea but it's it's
just a wonderful wonderful move this
Bishop to a5 just you know the the final
nail in the coffin where where you allow
black to have a queen on the board and
even he will not lose it immediately but
you know everything is precisely
calculated and it was in this position
after Bishop to a5 that Geoffrey younggu
resigned to the game and a first victory
for Fabiano Khurana in a long time so
Magnus Carlsen will not be able to troll
him on Twitter anymore
at least not on that regard and like I
said I did prepare the standings after
round six of the US Championship 2019 so
let's check it out
in first place with four out of six the
only person he Cora Nakamura then with
three and a half we have four people in
here Dominguez Perez Fabiana Corwin on
out with this victory Wesley so and
Samuel 7 then with three points three
people Alexandre Linderman ray Robson
and Jeffries young now after losing this
game with two and a half I wonder Lange
and Samuel Franklin
last year's winner but you know it's
still early he might he might get up
there the end in last place with two
points of our Vajrasana Cobian and timur
garea a team or grave although he is
definitely one of the most exciting
players to play in this championship and
you know
worldwide even you know with with
exciting games you will not often see
many points it's just the way it just
works but yeah whenever you get a chance
to check out again by team or Gary have
you know do check it out uh yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it and
that you enjoy my short coverage of the
u.s. championship 2019 so far I would
like to thank Dennis is on fellini
magnus carlsen dominic Evert Kai's
double bass and Miller who change for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon with some more 60
frames-per-second action and yeah
decision I have an excellent rest of
your day